[Music]
since 1877 the biodarka valley has
continued to perform
but it takes hard work and years of
training to be able to pull off a
performance which continues to sell out
at moscow's historic portrait theater
there's no time to think of the conflict
which has dominated the airwaves but
internationally Russian Art and artists
are increasingly being shunned
Ukraine has removed Russian poet and
writer Alexander Pushkin and others from
most public spaces
even scientists and writers like
lemonosov are no longer allowed to be
visible
Ukraine wants its allies in the west to
boycott Russian culture as well
Moscow calls it a manifestation of
discrimination against Russian artists
and limiting cultural interaction
in recent weeks the foreign Ministry has
summoned the Italian and Dutch
ambassadors for shunning Russian
performers
upsetting the Russian artists but they
remain undeterred
which is right
canceling Russian culture I feel sorry
pity for these people I can't even
understand who could think of canceling
Tchaikovsky I think these are shallow
narrow-minded politicians who make
decisions like that
from Tolstoy to Tchaikovsky art and
culture has a special place in Russian
Society
many countries have canceled or
restricted Russian performances since
the invasion of Ukraine but for those
who dedicated their lives to Performing
Arts they say it's unfair for them to be
dragged into politics
Russians are also concerned about
cultural appropriation artist Archie
coinji is now labeled as a Ukrainian at
New York's Metropolitan Museum of Art
kunji died in 1910 in the Russian Empire
while Ukraine as a state only existed
from 1918.
critics say Russian painter Ivan
ivazovsky who died in 1900 has recently
been made Ukrainian
[Music]
a star conductor Valerie gar gave and
prominent pianist Denise matsuev are no
longer performing at New York's famed
Carnegie Hall for their Pro Kremlin
views
and the Metropolitan Opera pulled
popular soprano and the natrapka from a
run of shows last year for quote not
demonstrating she had seriously distant
herself from President Vladimir Putin
in Austria Canada Switzerland and Poland
soloists and orchestras have faced
similar actions
the Royal Opera House's famous Covent
Garden banned bolshei ballet's London
tour
from the age of 10 they started the
academy and continue like that for 30 35
years now think about it every day from
morning till evening your work
translates into tremendous physical
exertion
Western Powers want Russians to distance
themselves from their government but
artists who always relied on patronage
and support from the state feel stifled
between warring people in power
Moscow
thank you